foreign
Brooklyn New York hi Joe welcome to
Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call a
long time listener and first time caller
thanks how can we help
yeah so I'm in a bit of a predicament
um and it involves uh basically a money
that I owe to family and friends as well
as an upside down car but I think what
kind of led to this situation kind of
goes back a few years maybe four to five
years when I became heavily involved
with Forex Trading or currency trading
um and eventually got me to a point
where I was losing a ton of money
started taking out credit cards and
funding
um kind of that endeavor that way and
then eventually when I ran out of uh
money out of my credit cards I would
start taking out personal loans once I
couldn't take out any more unsecured
loans I started taking loans against my
car and then eventually ended up
borrowing from friends and family and so
you sound like a panic this sounds like
an addiction yeah it was an addiction
um and so unfortunately it got to a
breaking point to where I had to file
for bankruptcy uh may as of last year
um but I did keep
um my secured loans as well as the money
I borrowed from my family and like I
went through therapy and all all that so
it was really a truly truly a traumatic
time for me and so I'm sorry now yeah
and like now I'm at a point where I just
really want to I have been actively
trying to tackle this
um the so what do you owe on the car
yeah so there are two cars involved
um my personal car I owe 13 600 at a
rate of 24.
and during the time
um I actually took a loan out
um and I used my brother's car as
collateral for 4 700 which is the
remaining balance as of today
okay and what is the 13 600 car worth
that's worth right around say like forty
three hundred dollars okay and what do
you make
uh my net income per month is 65.50 okay
and you live in Brooklyn New York
yeah
ouch
okay because you got an expensive place
to live right
no no luckily
um my one of my brothers and I we found
a pretty uh inexpensive place to live so
my rent right now is right around 1100
which includes utilities and that's my
share what do you do for a living
uh I am in business development and
sales for a tech startup here in Midtown
Manhattan
if you work more there does your income
change
um as of right now I'm like tapped out
with like the number of hours I'm
putting in I'm like working from like 7
30 in the morning on up until like 7 30
in the evening like Monday through
Friday all right here's what I would do
if I woke up in your shoes
all right I yeah are these your only two
debts no you have the family did yeah I
have my family debt
um totaling ninety thousand dollars
man I'm sorry
okay
um well your brother's car concerns me
more than yours
yeah because you need you need the you
need the stress of not screwing up his
life off of your back
yeah that would bother me more than my
own personal car does it you
uh yes it does it's it's yeah and
they're almost the same amount no no
yeah and it's a smaller amount I'm sorry
it's 14. so that's easy anyway so what I
would do is you know start doing a
really really tight budget and just
attack his debt like a Vengeance knock
it out then attack your car debt and
just knock it out there's not another
answer for it you just got to live on
absolutely nothing and really in about
four or five months you ought to go
knock both of these out
if you just live on nothing you don't do
anything anyway but work so you don't
need to go out and party or go out to
restaurants you don't need money you got
to put it all on this and so hey we're
going to help you with part of your
healing we're going to put you through
Financial Peace University hold on I'll
have them have Austin pick up and get
you signed up for that